dernier élément de ce dossier il est un
peu plus politique une passe d'armes
très animé qui a opposé à l'assemblée
nationale cet après-midi simone veil
un député socialiste qui réclamait un
plan d'ensemble contre la grande
pauvreté
quand monsieur le président premier
ministre le gouvernement nous proposera
t-il un plan national ambitieux liant le
logement l'accès aux soins à l'éducation
et à l'emploi conforme aux
préoccupations d'une véritable
solidarité
monsieur le député en vous écoutant
parler j'ai vraiment eu le sentiment que
vous pariez de la situation dans
laquelle j'ai trouvé le ministère de la
santé
oui oui
et oui et oui monsieur emmanuelli vous
pouvez hocher la tête vous bougez hocher
la tête j'ai passé la journée depuis
hier j'ai passé la journée depuis hier
avec des représentants d'associations et
ils nous ont dit que pour la première
fois il y avait un programme d'ensemble
mais qu'est ce que vous avez fait
franchement bien bien là du tout
non